[موسيقى]
انا ك مثلا سينمائيه الهمتني جدتي لانها
كانت دائما يعني تسرد لنا القصص الجميله
من التراث الغني الاماراتي فحابه انا صوت
الشعب الاماراتي والصوره
وجماليه تقول نحن جماليه الصوره تكون
موجوده في كل شاشه في العالم فدائما صوت
المراه لها رونق خاص لها لمسه
[موسيقى]
خاصه مجال الاخراج مجال صعب جدا لان ذكوري
بعدين المراه دخلت في مجال الاخراج في
الثمانينات في امريكا او في الدول يعني
الثاني مش في الوطن العربي ودخلنا نحنا في
هال السياق السينمائي بالذات شويه متاخر
ولكن نفس الوقت مع الذكور يعني
في موازنه جدا جميله او معادله متوازنه
بين الذكور والنساء في مجال الاخراج في
الوطن العربي فقط اما اذا شفنا برع
الامارات في خلل كبير في عدد النساء من
الرجال يعني كمثال بسيط جدا على كل عشره
افلام يخرجونها يعني باخراج رجل فقط فيلم
واحد من اخراج
[موسيقى]
مراه
القسم الاول في نقص في عدد من المنتجين
اللي هم عندهم ايمان قوي في المراه
العربيه اللي ممكن تخرج بطريقه عالميه رقم
اثنين ممكن عوائد عائليه او اجتماعيه تمنع
المراه انها تدخل في هذا المجال المحور
الثالث والاهم المستثمرين نحنا شفت انا
دراسه كانت طالعه يعني حديثه ان كل ما ما
الميزانيه للفيلم زادت كل ما المراه
استبعدت من الموضوع في علامه يعني استفهام
كبير في الموضوع وهذا اكتشفوا ان الناس
اللي يوقعون على الوثائق هذه اللي تصدر
وتعطي المجال للذكور ان يخرجون كلهم ذكور
فنحتاج نساء اكثر في الاماكن اللي فيها
قرارات والسبب الاخير المراه نفسها احيانا
المراه نفسها هي تسوي عوائق لنفسها تبني
خوف
[موسيقى]
جدا فخوره كمرا اماراتي مخرجه عندي فيلمين
على نتفليكس ورلد وايد اكثر من 140 دوله
في العالم هذا طبعا اعطاني حافز كبير اني
ابني اسمي وفي مجال السينما بحث واسوي او
انتج واخرج فيلمي الاول بعنوان ثلاثه مع
الممثل العالمي جفرسون هول ومثلين جدا
راقين من الامارات ايضا مثل مرعي الحليان
احمد نورا العابد وغيرهم السعود الزرعوني
طالعين طلعه جدا جميله
وال الهدف ان اسوي فيلم يكون بين ثقافتين
بين عالمين مختلفين ويكون بينهم يعني دافع
واحد انهم ينقضون الطفل هذا في الفيلم
فهذا اول فيلم عندي طويل بينزل قريبا وبعد
ما ينزل هذا الفيلم عندي افلام ثانيه في
السينما ايضا طويله ومسلسلات ف الهدف اني
انتج او ادخل هذا الفورمات اللي هو يسمونه
الفورمات الافلام الطويله ان شاء الله
ويكون لي استوديو يوم من الايام اني انتج
لغيري ايضا انا اشوف ان اكبر انجاز لي ان
كتبت فيلم اسمه باب مع مسعود عمر العلي
بصبغه او بخط قوي جدا من موسيقه اي الرحمن
الفايز باوسكار عالميين فعندي هال الاسامي
الثقيله الموجوده في الفيلم وايضا بيتم
احلى شيء في الموضوع انه
بيتم انتاج الموسيقى للفيلم باول اوركسترا
عالميه موجود فيها اكثر من 80 مراه عالميه
في هذه
[موسيقى]
الاوركسترا نصيحتي لكل مراه اماراتيه
خليجيه عربيه حابه تدخل هذا المجال المجال
الحين اكثر صار مرونه فيه وسهوله خاصه مع
انطلاقه
كل البلاتفورم الموجودين من شاهد الى
غيرهم فعندكم فرصه فلا انكم تنمون
المهارات هاي ويطلع صوتكم السينمائي بقوه
ايضا والنصيحه ممكن اقول اللي هي فعلا انا
استفدت منها التطوع التطوع اهم شيء يوم
المراه تتطوع في حقول سينمائيه او تشتغل
مع مخرجين اكبر تتعلم وتشوف من عندهم
الايجابيه جدا مهمه في الحياه ايضا
الواقعيه انا الشخص اللي الهمني اكثر شخص
في حياتي امي اللي هي فاطمه عمار الخاجه
لان ما في انسان في الحياه كلها في طاقه
ايجابيه مثل هي فدائما اذا تشوف ان المكان
مولع في نار وفي مشاكل دائما هي بتلف
الناس كلها بتشوف ص يمين امي بتشوف اليسار
وبتشوف الفرصه الموجوده في المكان اللي
فيه مثلا مشكله كبيره فهاي العمليه علمتني
اني احل المشاكل دائما العقل ايجابي يولد
دائما امور ايجابيه في
الحياه